today Christophe Bauer is going for a
spin and a very special VW Beetle at the
time considered the Volkswagen for high
society it's a romesco at one time it
was common practice to buy just a
drivable chassis from a car maker and
then have the body custom made
what he may think about this stuff
explains that before world war 2 romich
mainly built taxis on opal chasse ease
during the war the company had to
concentrate on producing field kitchens
it was only in the 1950s that it was
able to return to its area of expertise
and started building exclusive
convertibles and four-door taxis out of
the still new VW Beetle Ramesh designer
Johannes visco began tinkering with a
special body of his own the result so
impressed the boss that he took it into
volume production Jesus ding that's
bound in Syria roemmich became one of
the first coach builders to mass produce
a special edition vehicle with its low
cost and robust engineering the beetle
provided the ideal platform it touched
off a veritable do it yourself boom
among coachbuilders
Portia utilize technology from VW for
its first mass-produced 356 s Abdullah
and boiler build cars virtually of their
own design on beetle chassis and VW
eventually itself followed suit with a
luxury coupe a in the shape of the
Karmann Ghia the sonoma christophe
recalls how the Romesh special sports
convertible was unveiled at the german
automobile exhibition in berlin in 1950
where the public crowded around to see
it Hollywood stars like Audrey Hepburn
and Gregory Peck were among those who
added the luxury VW's from Berlin to
their collections with sales booming
roemmich open showrooms in Munich Zurich
Ottawa Stockholm and even Hollywood so
got in Hollywood but Volkswagen chief
Heinrich nordhoff was less than pleased
with romances success at first the coach
builder procured the VW chassis straight
from the manufacturer but later VW
reserved that privilege for romances
rival Carmen Bromwich was obliged to
cannibalize new fully assembled beetles
I ready and those who know the VW Beetle
will have no trouble handling or a match
bc AO records christophe but everything
looks more stylish and luxurious better
interiors than this were hardly
conceivable in those days and even in
terms of acceleration speed and road
holding it was far superior to the
beetle that came from the low
aerodynamic body and lightweight
construction the driver's seat feels
extremely low but that's only because of
the high sides you have to crane your
neck to see the street oh yeah I'm less
for those deposits is in the countryside
is quite spectacular around the trentino
region of northern Italy
meeting desire she can come alongside
the smart convertible version romich
made a coupe a that's now quite rare the
craftsmanship was of the finest all done
by hand and the car weighed only 800
kilograms all these hand forged body
sections are made of lightweight
aluminum attached to a fine metal frame
much like carrots area Turing's
legendary Superleggera construction from
the visual standpoint designer Johannes
bisco went for a compact Ponton body
with a delicately curved beltline some
people nicknamed the car the banana but
banana isn't right for such an elegant
car and that's why for the first time in
automotive history they decided to badge
the entire name back to the rear model
bisco in fine chrome of them Hector
Platts Ian madera base core in fines to
comb
designer Johannes beasts go was not
stingy with the chrome the silvery lines
highlight the extravagant yet purest
design
you
the beasts go is actually a three-seater
with the rear seat mounted sideways
behind the driver
tryout info the romesco was awarded the
Golden Rose at the geneva motor show two
years running 1954 1955 after that it
was advertised as the most beautiful and
internationally acclaimed sports
convertible but the idea of it being a
sports car shouldn't be taken too
seriously the generous engine
compartment was occupied by a 1 point 1
liter VW boxer with a paltry 25
horsepower although this particular
model has Porsche power a 1.5 litre 60
horsepower engine from a 356 that's more
like it this is christophe each other
with the Porsche engine the beasts go
can reach 145 km/h but just 105 with the
beetle unit even so thanks to its
lightweight construction and streamlined
body the beasts co leaves a VW Bug of
the same period for dust Gaby's cool the
beasts co was for individualists with
deep pockets as christophe and costs
about twice as much as the VW Beetle at
the time there's a story that a German
movie star wanted to buy the very first
beast go right at the motor show but
Friedrich roemmich didn't yet have a
list price and glanced over at the
Porsche stand where the new 356 had been
unveiled it had a price tag of 10,000
Deutsche marks so be scoped said 9800
and the actor paid up coolbaugh dumped
inside
with the success of the luxury beetle
derivative Volkswagen quickly made plans
for a sports car of its own based on the
beetle and commissioned coachbuilder
Carmen to build it starting in 1956 the
head of Carmen's technical development
team was none other than Johannes beasts
go Christophe observes that when VW
rolled out the Karmann Ghia in 1955
sales of the beast coat slumped that was
to be expected since the ghia was 1500
Deutsche marks cheaper and bore VW seal
of quality and so after seven years in
production yielding 280 handmade special
models it was the end of the road for
the beasts Co but it remains the first
sporty luxury car on the VW beetle
platform and a clear milestone in
automotive history the beasts co was a
design pioneer Mercedes copied the
eyebrows over the wheel wells on its
legendary 1955 300 SL and decades later
in 1998 Audi's TT recalled the style of
the nearly 50 years older will match
you